it's very windy
i don't know if the audio is going to
make it
[Music]
all right today we are going to the
beach it's luca's first time and super
excited because ever since he has been
born we've been stuck at the house we've
taken him out to a few restaurants here
and there and can't say it's
super enjoyable because me and tiff end
up taking turns eating i'll take care of
luca and i'm just staring at her eat we
switch off and then she's staring at me
tips already uh gathered some chairs our
little wagon thing
some goodies are in here nice i think
we're all set so
[Music]
cool are we ready for our first family
outing
[Applause]
our first beach trip are you ready to go
to the beach
last time we came you were in my belly
true i was like i want to be there
already are we there yet are we there in
are we there yet all right so we have
the usual suspects me tiff
baby we also got isaac with us today
he's somewhere in the back
and uh we got nana
[Music]
what is this madness
i want to go back home
this is crazy it's too bright first time
in nature
[Music]
i love how isaac is old enough now to
take over all the big boy
responsibilities now i don't got to be
in charge of all the heavy lifting no
more
you okay
he's like this
is so cute
we're so close
we made a look at baby
like i don't care
i'm just trying to survive
at least it's not cold
true
[Music]
are you happy true at the beach for your
first time
you know i have pictures of my first
time at the beach my parents had me
naked did you like
it for that it's not hot enough
finally get some nature in you boy
you've been indoors for your whole life
how do you like the
beach experience
[Music]
actually this is oc water
[Music]
all right so i have luca here he's
asleep
i don't know you can see but he fell
asleep and
my mom and casey left just left me and
isaac here because casey was eating some
of the snacks that i brought and he was
like oh these would go good with some
beer my mom was like i want a beer let's
go look for some beer so they they left
to go find some beer isaac was playing
with a boomerang that we brought and he
was trying to learn how to throw it so
he launched it and it actually came back
but it's like pretty windy so the wind
picked it up and it just flew
and he ran to go get it and it ended up
just
falling into the ocean so we lost the
boomerang
[Music]
all right so the beach day was fun fast
forward a couple days this week tiff's
mission statement is to cook
more for the family and now i've always
been the cook in this house tiff wants
to take over more and be able to provide
for the kids in terms of you know mom's
cooking so this is her first week trying
so look i bought all these books
to try to make some meals try to learn
about you know the foods that we put in
our bodies anyway this week has been the
first week that i'm like really trying
to hit every meal breakfast lunch dinner
i'm trying to make something you're on
it i love it i love this provide for the
family
and so today's lunch which is actually
closer to dinner now because it took a
long time to go to the grocery store
what are you making i'm making burgers
for lunch
okay this is my first time making
burgers well technically like i i kind
of i made my own patty i remember
because it was like a heart shape when
we lived in the old house when you were
making hamburgers yeah yeah so that was
the last time i ever like attempted
burgers okay so i totally forgot like
some crucial things about making burgers
what crucial things number one is don't
need oil on the pan because the ground
beef like it's pretty fatty ground beef
oils so whatever like the pan is hella
oily and then the other really important
thing is the fact that in order to make
a patty to like fit a bread you have to
start off like freaking gigantic because
it's drinks
oh is that what are you what are your
patties look like
oh he's not mean
what taunting me
it's hilarious
shut up i'm trying okay look this one
this is the last bit of the meat so
you're making extra big now because look
at this
yes all right so the first batch i fit
three of them on this pan because they
were like okay this is about the size of
a patty you can fit three of them on
this pan okay
[Music]
so this is the first one
here's the first one the size of a
chicken nugget and this is so these
three i did first because i was like
okay this one's like about the right
size i'll do that one the same and then
i was like well just in case let me make
it bigger so this is the third one and
then these two were the same size so
that i did that one and then after
seeing this outcome i'm like okay hold
on i need to do it really big it's like
way bigger and it still came out pretty
like flat i guess so that one was the
most like the most recent one that i
made and then this is the last one so
tell me before i ruin this meat like is
this fine i usually don't make mine that
flat but look how fat they pop up yeah
you want it to be about like this size
but thicker you want more meat we don't
have more meat about one pound and this
is like one pound of beef right it's all
one pound theoretically one pound of
beef is good for four
burger patties like if they're like
normal sized
two three four five six i made six
though i was actually trying to make
eight
[Laughter]
[Music]
because there's eight there's
fun
so that's why the first ones came out so
small cause i i didn't eat it up to
you know what's even cuter is i was
editing and i got bored and i was like
oh what's tiff doing i didn't want to
come down because uh luke is sleeping in
the office what are you watching me yeah
i was watching you so we had these
cameras right so i was watching you and
i i happened to tune in right when you
were making the patties
it looked like it was a lot of work
because you're like really in it you're
like putting elbow grease together
because that part so
the meat i put it in the fridge so it
was frozen i put in the fridge yesterday
so i'm like cool a whole night like this
would probably be depressing
and then
i get home from the grocery store and
then i text casey i'm like oh my god the
ground beef is still frozen so then he's
like okay put it in water and that was
like would it be faster if it's like
directly in the water because he's like
no the meat's gonna disintegrate in the
water it's gonna fall apart stay in the
packaging so i'm like okay cool that
makes sense i ended up like leaving it
in the water for some time and then i'm
like man isaac's gonna get home now i
told him he could hang out with his
friends like by the time he gets home
the food will be ready and like the
whole outside of the package was still
like mushy so i'm like okay cool i think
it's good so then i open it and then as
i'm like
like mushing it around my hands like the
very very center was still frozen so
what you're watching is like me trying
to work out the frozen meat
trying to like make it not so frozen and
i also was seasoning it with laurie so
i'm like i don't know let's see let's
see how this turns out yeah so they
could also be very salty patties very
tiny thin salty panties i'll still eat
it i'm excited
you trying is cute and sexy thank you i
tried i tried oh but i was really proud
and excited about the fact that i
actually sliced the tomatoes i can't
ever slice tomatoes like ever like to
save my life and this knife was amazing
oh yeah
yeah i like that knife too it's one of
my favorite knives we have yeah they
sponsored big moons before so that's how
we have that knife i'll eat this patty
this will be my burger you're gonna
enjoy that cause it's tiny you're gonna
love it it's so cute oh i'm gonna
actually cut the burger yeah you should
you should
it's a krabby patty
patty okay anyways let me check on the
baby because uh he's been sleeping for
like three hours now and he's still
sleeping
[Music]
how's it going
i'm making my tangles
oh nice
it's the smallest little burger ever i
love it it's so tiny that's true krabby
patties from spongebob are actually
really small looking don't they yeah
true but look come on they still came
out pretty good yours and isaac's are
decent that looks good oh my mouth is
watering
look at my tiny little burger they all
eat these
what are you doing
using the rest of the bread that i put
out for my other tiny patty that is epic
these are my burgers
it's a set
we rolled for the good ones
for the record these ones look fantastic
for the record thank you
thank you
what was your thought process that you
watched the burger patties like shrink
before you're riding
i was like oh
no i made them too small maybe this
other one is big enough no you know
what's hilarious isaac came home and he
was like whoa those were tiny and i was
like oh crap even isaac knows i messed
up
yeah you have to make them bigger
true
actually isaac's probably the best
burger maker in the family because he's
he's the one that likes making burgers
and he's he's a good fry cook evan made
burgers in a while though because last
time i made it the heat was too high the
inside of the burger was raw and the
outside was cooked oh my god that's just
made me nervous for a whole nother
reason i don't know if these are fully
collected i hope they are let's find out
high five
[Music]
you